a lot of people set financial goals I'm
successful when they make my first
million okay now I have to make my
second million its success is a feeling
and and it's the feeling of contribution
and if I were to focus on whether or not
does this make financial sense and
really hold myself back and not come
from a place of serving others and
contributing that wouldn't have happened
my success wasn't based on how I could
push down everybody that was around me
my success was based on how much I could
push everybody up rise and shine it
since preso time good morning belief
nation my name is Lily and my one word
is extraordinary I believe that every
single human being is capable of
extraordinary things when they really
embrace who they truly are so let's
start your day off right together and go
grab yourself a cup of coffee and step
on today's message serve others over to
you simon Sinek so how do you define
success I think success is is is seeing
those around you work to their natural
best and creating momentum for a vision
towards a vision that will last beyond
yourself so a guy is driving a bus for
20 years got to retire he's on Madison
Avenue in New York packed every day as
people getting on that bus and getting
off mm-hmm yes two kids wife lives in
Queens
mm-hmm he might call himself successful
another guy might be vice president of
that company
we'll call self unsuccessful so his
success what you make of it its
successes of feeling it's not it's not a
series of checkmarks and goals
I think people define success as as
finish lines you know they well I ran a
marathon I'm successful the question is
a why did you run the marathon and what
happens after you've completed the
marathon do you just keep running
marathons what happens if you break your
leg and you can no longer run marathons
you know we set a lot of people set
financial goals I'm successful when they
make my first million okay now I have to
make my second million
it's success as a feeling and and it's
the feeling of contribution so you're a
bus driver in Queens if he has decided
that his job as a bus driver is to
ensure that everyone who gets on his bus
feels better about themselves because
they got on his bus and not another bus
and so he greets them with a smile he
says good morning he says goodbye that
people remember that that that that ride
that they took with him versus the this
vice president of the company who's made
it about himself and his financial goals
he's the one who's unhappy as opposed to
seeing those around him succeed and
those around him go home with a love of
their their day you know because they
come to work in his company every day so
I still believe success and and good
leadership are about service to others
serving others is one of the most
fulfilling things you could ever do in
your life sure you can be very
successful on paper you could reach your
goals but the idea of true fulfillment
comes from really contributing to others
into the world and at first it may not
make a lot of sense it may not make
sense in terms of your finances or the
ROI so for example for me I run a nine
week course which is a live training
series called a school of life and on
the surface it's taking up a lot of my
time and I put in all my might and all
my effort into this program and it may
not make financial sense to me in the
short term but what I get from that is
that I'm able to contribute back I'm
able to serve others just last night I
had an amazing session and one of the
women was holding on to the story of her
life that she's just not good enough it
just kept on coming up over and over and
over again and it hindered her from
having the relationships that she wanted
it hindered her from starting her
business and every day she would just
think of this thing that she's just not
good enough
so yesterday with all my might I just
went in I think we need to fix this
right now because if you don't you're
not gonna have the life that you want
and this is the school of life this is
what we're here to do we're here to
transform each other
and I just kept on pushing and really I
wasn't thinking about houses gonna make
sense for me and turns in my checkbox is
it gonna make sense financially it
doesn't but the feeling I got from like
serving her and serving others and the
more I pushed the more she opened up and
eventually the floodgates just opened up
and she just like released everything
and she realized the reason why she was
holding on to not being enough is
because she had this childhood memory of
this boy that said that she was not
pretty enough to date and at that point
the entire group just cheered her on and
the approval she didn't need from us the
approval she needed in herself she
finally saw the beautiful person that we
saw in her and it was the most emotional
session we've ever had we never cried so
much we never laughed so much we really
felt truly connected and four of them
are actually gonna meet each other in
person very soon in the summer and if I
were to focus on whether or not does
this make financial sense and really
hold myself back and not come from a
place of serving others and contributing
that wouldn't have happened so sometimes
it doesn't make sense financially or or
the ROI sometimes we just really need to
connect with our hearts and feel the
feeling of fulfillment which is really
coming from a place of serving others so
I'm gonna put this challenge on you guys
today whatever it is that you're doing
find a small way to really serve others
it could be holding a door open for
someone buying someone a cup of coffee
helping out a friend that needs some
encouragement supporting people going on
YouTube and writing comments to smaller
channels you know how hard it is
starting out that they could really use
the encouragement do something today to
really serve others and I promise you
it's going to be one of the most
fulfilling things that you're gonna do
today I have a special bonus clip for
you but before we get to that the
question of the day is how are you going
to serve others
today right in the comments below and
I'll join in on the discussion thank you
so much for watching I believe in you
and I hope you continue to believe in
yourself
and whatever your one word is and we'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
[Music]
how does it feel to be an inspiration to
many people who struggle with life does
he feel that pressure yeah that's an
intense question so he's in eighth grade
eighth grade yeah
asking existential questions how people
feel or respond to me I don't think
about that actively because it's not i
don't i'm not what i don't do what i do
to have that effect because that would
imply that i wake up in the morning and
say how can i know i'm a perfect day for
me is when the phone does not ring and
when my inbox is empty
that's a perfect day and i can stay home
play with the kids watch a movie on the
couch with popcorn with slightly too
much butter and just veg but what
happens is i get called
i get called by the press because the
universe flinched i get called by a
school you call by a city but by
organizers of a theater you know or
lecture halls and they want to learn
about the universe and in that capacity
I'm a servant of the public's curiosity
about the cosmos and in in that way I'm
not asking myself how am i affecting you
I'm simply offering all that I can and
all that I know of this beautiful
universe in which we live and that's
that's what I do and why I think gets
the advantage that that my generation
had is when we were in film school and
we're starting in the film business the
door was absolutely locked and it was a
very very high wall and nobody got in
there for all of us beggars and
scroungers down at the front gate
decided that if if we didn't sort of
band together we wouldn't survive and
that if one could make it that one would
help all the others make it and we would
continue to help each other so we banded
together I mean that's that's how Kalin
figured it out any society starts that
way any society begins by realizing them
together by helping each other you can
survive better than if you fight each
other and compete with each other if I
got a job I would help somebody else get
a job if somebody got more successful
than me
it was partly my success I wasn't my
success wasn't based on how I could push
down everybody that was around me my
success was based on how much I could
push everybody up and eventually their
success was the same way and in the
process they pushed me up and I pushed
them up and we kept doing that and we
still do that and even though we all
have in essence competing companies we
see it as if everybody succeeds or my
friends succeeds that everybody succeeds
so that that and that's the key to it is
to have everybody succeed not to gloat
over somebody else's failure one of the
basic motifs of fairytales is that you
find the poor unfortunate along the side
of the road and when they beg for help
if you give it to them
you end up succeeding if you don't give
it to them you end up being turned into
a frog or something so it's something
that's been around for thousands of
years a concept that's been around for
thousands of years and it is even more
necessary today when people are much
more into their own in grand iseman than
they are in helping other people I mean
the one thing about you here at the
Academy here is constantly about public
service about helping others I don't
think there's anybody who's become
successful that doesn't understand how
important it is to be part with a larger
community to help other people and
larger community to give back to the
community and it's not something you do
you start doing when you've made it now
I'm on the top I can sort of enhance my
joy and and self-esteem by helping the
poor underlings it's when you are at the
very lowest level and you're struggling
when we were in film school we were all
very very poor we were all very very
struggling we all need jobs very
desperately and if one of us couldn't
get a particular job we'd send another
friend in on the interview because we
were hoping that one of us would get the
job and so you'd do it right from the
very beginning you can start every
single day you know whether it's helping
your brother or sister or helping your
peers at school or helping in the
community but it's not just
not just a kind of public service thing
it's a way of life if America is the
pursuit of happiness the best way to
pursue happiness is to help other people
because there's nothing else that will
make you happy you can be as rich and
famous and powerful as you want to be
and it will not bring you happiness and
that's said over and over and over again
in such a cliche that it hardly goes it
art it needs to be said but people don't
understand that it's actually true and
you can find people rich powerful and
famous and they aren't happy and you can
find people who have discovered the fact
that it's really helping people it's
really being compassionate or other
human beings that makes you happy at the
risk of sounding like a Miss America
[ __ ] contestant the most fulfilling
things I've experienced have truly been
the human interactions spending time
with women and village banks in Mexico
with finca microfinance organization
meeting young women who were the first
and only in their communities to attend
secondary school in rural Kenya with
free the children a group that build
sustainable schools in developing
countries trekking with gorillas
conservationists in Rwanda it's a cliche
because it's true
that helping others ends up helping you
more than anyone getting out of your own
concerns and caring about someone else's
life for a while reminds you that you
are not the center of the universe
and that in the ways we are generous or
not we can change the course of
someone's life even at work the small
feats of kindness crew members directors
fellow actors have shown me have had the
most lasting impact raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
we believe that people with passion
not one drop of myself work depends on
your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual Clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details